Speaker 1: so we've covered one side of the
Liz Cheney fiasco, which is Republicans have
stripped Republican Congresswoman Liz Cheney
from her leadership role because she admits
Joe Biden won the election and Trump is lying
when he says that he won and he should stop.
That's the one side.
Now, on the other side of that is that Liz
Cheney was replaced by someone and that someone
is Republican Congresswoman Elise Stefanik,
who now becomes Republican conference chair
after Liz Cheney's removal.
The pro Trump right wing is going absolutely
crazy about Elise Stefanik.
They just love her.
And sadly, Elise Stefanik is sort of a better
spoken Marjorie Taylor Greene or Lauren Bobber.
She's just as nutty.
Don't be confused.
She just knows how to better present her ideas
to appear less outrageous.
And case in point, she gets herself a congratulatory
pat on the back interview on Fox News this
weekend, conducted by none other than Trump,
suck up Maria Bartiromo.
And right away it goes to the Big Lie about
the election being stolen.
And again, Stefanik doesn't indicate that
her opinion is any different than Marjorie
Taylor Greens on this issue.
She just knows how to better frame her answer
to be about her constituents and election
integrity.
But she has no problem accepting Maria Bartiromo
framing of the question.
So check it out and understand that Maria's
question is, do you think there will be a
fair election in twenty, twenty two, which
will allow you to investigate the twenty twenty
election, which was of course, stolen?
It's a ridiculous question.
And here's how it leads to Fennec answers
it.
Speaker 3: Are you expecting a free and fair
election to enable you to do that next year?
Well, that's one of the really important issues,
Maria, when I go home to my district and I
talk to my colleagues, this is the case across
the country.
Voters want to make sure that they have faith
in our election system, which is why election
integrity and election security is a top priority
for the American people.
And it should matter to you whether you're
Republican, Democrat or independent.
This is why you're seeing state legislatures
like Florida, like Arizona, taking action
to address and strengthen their election systems.
Speaker 1: This is why she's so slippery.
That's right.
Americans care about secure election systems
and we have them.
The 20 20 election was not close.
It was one of the most secure that we've had.
And as always, with some anecdotal instances
of irregularities, not nearly a fraction of
what you need to change the results in any
one state.
It doesn't matter, though, because that's
not what Elise Stefanik will tell you.
She'll tell you since it matters to my constituents.
It was also irregular.
We need major action.
What they mean by this is we didn't suppress
enough of the vote in 2020.
If you look at her comments outside of this
interview, since her election, since the election,
you get a sense for her point of view.
She's promoted conspiracy theories about a
stolen election hours after the invasion of
the Capitol on January 6th.
She voted against accepting Pennsylvania's
electoral votes.
On January 12th, Harvard University announced
they are removing Stefanic from its Institute
of politics because of her role in promoting
these false claims.
But she's better at talking about it to sound
marginally less off the wall than some of
her colleagues.
And that makes her dangerous.
Here's a little bit more and then it sort
of comes mask off.
Speaker 3: We need voter ID.
We need chain of custody when it comes to
the absentee mail in ballots, signature verifications.
And what the Democrats have put forward is
a federal takeover to put them into power
forever.
The for the Politicians Act, H.R. one, which
would be taxpayer funded campaigns
Speaker 1: completely off the rails, a sensible
reform, sensible reforms are radical, far
left.
It's absolutely a crazy authoritarian clamp
down on voting, which they want.
Republicans are talking about election integrity,
but that's not really what they want here.
She's horrifying.
And then just for a little more flavor, the
interview ends with Elise Stefanik talking
about how great Donald Trump is.
It's almost like a rite of passage on Maria
Bartiromo show.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Real quick, Congressman, before you go, President
Trump supported you to get the third highest
rank in the GOP.
How important is he to the party right now?
He's critical to the party, he is the leader
of the Republican Party, voters determine
the leader of the Republican Party and they
continue to look to President Trump for his
vision.
And he's going to be an important part of
us winning back the house in twenty, twenty
two.
All right.
We will leave it there.
Congrats again, Congressman.
We hope you'll come back.
We will be watching the developments.
Thank you so much.
Speaker 1: So there it is, pledging full and
total loyalty to Donald Trump.
It's all his for the taking.
And as far as Elise Stefanik is concerned,
Trump gets to pick Republican winners in twenty
twenty two and Trump gets to run in twenty
twenty four if he so wants.
And she will support him blindly and to the
ends of the earth.
This is the Republican Party right now.
Cheney out.
That's what Liz Cheney was replaced by.
And if this tells us anything about the next
couple of years, it's that it doesn't seem
the Republican Party is going to be freeing
itself from the grip of Trump.
Send me your thoughts.
If you disagree, you can find us on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
Find me on Instagram at David Pakman